my name is Kelly massa I'm here to
moderate the bafta session sound I'm
gonna start from the far side we have
representing bridge of spies Richard
Holmes and drew Union and represent in
Mad Max we have Greg Rudolph and Mark
mangini can you guys talk about the
general soundscape of the film and your
approach to bridge of spies it's
interesting the way it works on wise
because it begins with this very rich
elegant mix of just atmospheric sounds
of the city of New York in the 50s
probably 10 minutes 12 minute section of
the film no dialogue at all
and once they start speaking which
happens about 10 minutes in if they
pretty much never stop talking it's very
very happy from my hand it was a very
wordy script as a lot of dialogue a lot
of information you tell me about your
own roles on the film and how you work
together we've never met because drew
he's going to go he's production
recorders so he's on from day one of
shooting and I come on after the first
Eddie is pretty much done so there's a
big world apart of light
mr. Spielberg's very concerned about
production sound he doesn't like ADR and
he didn't will replace any lines and so
they went to some extreme lengths on
that film of dubiously giving me the
honor of checking this production sound
which makes us enemies immediately who
wants have their work inspected you know
they also gave us the power to call up
and say the Wardrobe needs to move the
mic stuff that was you know historically
never allowed so since then every film I
get to listen to the dailies and I had
it's true dailies of course I'm
powerless all I can do is say this
sounds a bit weird because they don't
give me picture as well so I'm listening
to sound and critiquing we know we had
no idea whether the mic was within 5
feet of the actor or a half a mile
we ended up recording I think 2880 our
lines and not all of those we use which
is pretty extraordinary considering how
many how much talent what
but Stephen is invested in wanting to
get good sound but it is problematic
depending where you are what you're
doing
we shot almost all real locations we
weren't on stages on a built set or a
soundstage it's much easier to get
cleaner isolated tracks because you're
in an artificial environment whereas we
had almost no sets in the interior of
the cockpit of the plane or and there
were very few it's difficult to shoot
between New York when there's real
traffic outside and you can't control
anything and also being a period film
the sounds aren't period-correct sirens
are that you have today didn't exist in
the 1950s also there say a difficult
thing when you use multiple cameras as
you can see here you have multiple
cameras shooting simultaneously but a
few of a wide shot in a tight shot and
you can't really get the microphone into
this where you need luckily we could
talk to Stephen and say this is really
important come on get in here I knew he
appreciates the value of what we can do
and is extremely cooperative and clever
that's in trying to make that happen so
it's good
I've never been to that corner before I
shot out in Queens it's like perfectly
period-correct you could look for
directions and you can see it on every
block it looks right for the 50s and I
know we had to clear everything away and
then we had a lot of cooperation from
the city and and they're able to stop
traffic a block away in each direction
so still there's a the brooklyn-queens
expressway is not far off from there so
we had to be got a little bit lucky with
the time of day we shot that bit and in
terms of the sounds get in the fan right
that was production effects but they've
added a lot of lovely atmosphere it's I
mean I that's what I like so much about
that it's all blended the 57 Chevy that
goes by the one I'd selected was
recorded originally on Crystal Skull and
had a bit of a slightly beefy sound on
it like slightly hot rod so we blended
yours with ours and there's a manhole
cover a thing in there that was barely
there in the end it was irritating they
go over the manhole covers of cooking
the car rolled over the brakes squeak
was added and I think the car comes in
is actually a Plymouth and we actually
went and recorded that from a
collector's car the usual thing the
battery went flat as soon as we went to
start it the sound we're not pushing it
down the road at Skywalker to get it
started
the tinging fan was something that gary
particularly liked rather than the clean
fan or you know particularly period fan
just wanted that thing sound and always
greater Foley details of the coin and
it's a very delicate stuff and the the
couple arguing it across the hall in the
New York apartment and then the violin
scale was being played and people
walking up stairs with hippie but
muffled feet all that stuff all sort of
gives it that feel of New York
excellent I'm gonna go to max mark Greg
can you talk about your respective roles
on the film and how you work together
much
I'm the Mad Max equivalent of Richard
Holmes I'm the supervising sound editor
and I'm also here with my co nominee
David White who is our sound designer
he's here in the front row and my job is
to record edit design all the sounds
that you will hear much like Richard
just talked about all these lovely
little D
tales that create a scene and then
provide them to Gregg to mix them to
create a finished and fleshed out proper
soundtrack what were the particular
challenges of Mad Max I mean as you can
imagine this is an incredibly dense film
sonically as well as visually so the
challenge was this year enormity and
capturing and editing that much sound
but I think our real success and Gregg
will speak to this in more detail was in
a movie that is arguably going to be a
loud movie how do we control that much
sound so that there's always focus and
there's always a narrative thread with
sound because the film visually is quite
dense you know Johnny seals frame is
unbelievably populated and there are
times I really believe it is the sound
that's helping give you focus the sound
kind of tells you where to look and is
telling a bit of the story because as
you know there's only about three words
in our entire film max grunts most of
the time and so it is often sound that's
helping tell the story along with the
visuals there's two avenues toward that
the first one as we were talking about
it it's what we refer to as a full trap
there's much information being given to
the audience at any one time we have to
make sure there's clarity there it can
become very muddled if you play
everything all the time it just turns
into a mush in the audience can just be
numbed to that but most importantly our
director George Miller really wanted
sound to be telling the story and for
him at any moment in the film there's
one sound that is the most important
sound and he would refer to that as top
of the pyramid so there's this constant
evolution of sounds and transitions from
one sound to another and the challenges
were to make those transitions without
being obvious about it but making sure
that the audience focus by the use of
this sound was telling the story point
that George wanted told it
particularly in the film if you take the
chase at the end of the film it's it's a
20 minute long chase across the desert
that ends the film in real life it would
have been a cacophony you have diesel
engines roaring you have explosions you
have weaponry you have screaming and
yelling and shouting and in real life
that had actually occurred it would have
been 20 minutes of ear bleed
so what Greg's referring to is that at
any given moment in that 20 minutes we
are constantly doing a weave to create
that focus to find the one sound or
maybe two sounds that help tell the
story and allows the audience's ears to
breathe a little bit
we're not going back we start with a
spanner banging on the side of an air
filter on a machine that's a very
realistic sound or diegetic if you want
to its source generated within the story
but we're then transitioning from that
into music and the drums is just showing
some of the transitions that we make
between source generated sounds and
sounds that are only there for the
audience and the mood that that will
help create the arc of emotion that the
filmmaker may be looking for at that
point in time it was important for
George to use sound to help sell the
point of view of the max character he's
basically subhuman at the beginning of
the film he's lost his family he feels
responsible he can't deal with it he's
crazy
so now he has to start to try to
reengage a bit with humanity we called
it Max's headspace sounds are hyper
realistic they're very focused to what
his focus is at that point of time when
his focus shifts the sound shifts when
you're dealing with other characters
that headspace goes away but now we're
back to realistic sounds so this is a
constant palette of sounds that are
changing it's trying to get transitions
that work for the moment but don't
distract the audience and David White
did a fabulous job in this area it's
interesting hearing you guys talk about
your challenges and all this dialogue
you were able to use we had the opposite
situation we had real vehicles that had
to be believable vehicles these are all
functioning cars with full-on massively
noisy engines the early stages for me
before the ADR was recorded we had to
retain some intelligibility out of those
those little bits of dialogue and of
course we're talking about replacing a
lot of the sound because shooting with
so many vehicles so many different
camera angles he can't really get a you
know smooth transition from one massive
car to another one but yes the sound
recording challenges I think we really
need to hear about from Ben here because
of the opposite of yours the main
challenge was actually getting George to
hear dialog from a cast in a big tanker
traveling at 60 80 plus kilometers an
hour and
off the road and sometimes some of the
vehicles were about 110 DB putting ears
on for example immortan we put a mic
inside his mask and had any as George
was in a another vehicle we were filming
with the edge arm traveling down low and
then coming back up to a close-up at the
same time and there's a stunt driver
actually driving the vehicle but Hugh
keays-byrne the actor had to turn around
and you know have a look at a particular
time so George was in another vehicle
maybe 500 metres away I was traveling
somewhere else so we had to design a
system for everybody to be able to hear
each other and communicate and that was
one of my big missions to do and on top
of that I was recording the vehicles on
the fly so it was all happening for six
months out and Namibian desert that was
a challenge for everybody but we loved
it I would like to thank Richard through
Greg Mark David and Ben for coming down
today it was very informative it was
great thank you
the reason I was excited about doing
Cinderella was I come straight off the
back of the wolf of wallstreet I could
not wait full of testosterone you know
and the only women in it would you know
had no clothes on so it was like I want
to do a girls film I want to do a film
about girls for girls you know what a
great child I've never done a fairy tale
before never done anything you know
aimed at children either
you
you